to defeat your opponent
you must become your opponent what's
your wow rabbit
and we are back live getting ready for
this final match up
maurice ashley he can still hear me but
he is nervous so i just want to point
that out to everybody that maurice
hey man you sweating a little bit
definitely i
you know i have to move quickly a one
minute i don't know given how
quickly he's played as well how well
i've seen him play so far
i just hope i have enough time because
his resistance is going to be the whole
thing how quickly
i can somehow get an advantage all right
and
just you seem you know pretty optimistic
right now rizzo what say you man what do
you think about this match of 10 minutes
for your boy against one from maurice
well this
is this is for me the rematch of the
century
you know like a few years ago some years
ago maurice came to the studio and put a
weapon on me
jezza uh masterchella and it was five
minutes to one minute
and none of us was able to get a victory
on him
um but since then you know it's been a
lot of games judges
as you can see his game is extremely
improved
and now he has double the odds so this
should be real exciting and real
interesting i'm really
interested to see what comes out of this
and i gotta honestly say
jesus is looking for revenge today guys
so let's see what happens it's gonna be
two games too right
uh i believe so let's get confirmation
of that and you know
how are you guys you guys feeling ready
for your your game
yes i'm good let's make it happen let's
get the show on the road
let's do it let's go
uh so we're about to see giza have
10 minutes till maurice is one maurice
you better have those wrists
stretched you know those fingers ready
it's not easy playing with one minute
thank you robert oh and we do have the
game underway maurice has the white
pieces
and he just dropped his bishop out and
look at jesus playing bishop e6
putting pressure on c4 rizzo what do you
think about the opening so far
light and fast i mean this is this is
kung fu
at his best and maurice has to he needs
to move as quickly as possible but he's
kind of quiet i thought he's gonna be
trash talking maurice
where's your head i ain't trying talking
this guy right now man i got to get my
game going
oh and jesus is
super quiet because we're all focused is
what it is
look at this guy he's not making any
mistakes yet
james what do you think about the early
going here um maurice keeping a great
pace
honestly great pace here but jizza got
time
and he fighting i mean this is not clear
like nobody's getting crushed or nothing
this is going to be a uh a fight as you
see
look at that bishop retweet b5 queen c2
i'm not liking him playing this well man
i'm not winning yet he playing it well
isn't he
he really is he's not normally this
quiet when you're playing chess right
he is super focused right now he has all
brain muscles moving
um and uh he's he's responding fast he
this is the fastest he was
he responded all day in fact
well maurice did just snag upon so i can
sense that maurice feeling a little bit
better about his chances but he only has
33 seconds
and giza continues to move at a pretty
lightning pace himself
queens came off so we got into the end
game
how is uh how is jizz's end gamer is how
does he do here
i think his end game is good he he he's
always
you know you know he understands hanging
pawn principles he understands
isolated pawn principle that's actually
one of my weaknesses
so let's see how high uh okay
i would say part of the issue is when
somebody has
27 seconds left the game should be as
complicated as possible but right now
honestly
jesus putting up some really stubborn
defense james it's only a one pawn
deficit you think he has
it in him to hold this off uh yes
actually well now too
okay well and maybe one let's see what
he does let's see but i think he can
hold it here he's actually fighting
this is uh very very tough for him to
face this
and i think jesus is taking the the the
the time advantage
he's using he uses a lot he's utilizing
his time in advance he knows that
oh my gosh i just blundered i saw you
wandered
i saw maurice's face he was not happy i
blundered did you see the draw a lot
oh i saw it but i wasn't gonna say
anything because i didn't want to give
any hints we'll definitely show that out
for the game but
wow what tenacious defense though i mean
look at this game
7.2 seconds so
he's gonna have to pre-move some moves
here but looks like he's getting that
queen
we got it here it comes
oh my gosh i pre-moved did you see that
blender that would have been a terrible
pre-move that was
awful maurice your face is awesome when
you premiere you get like all scared did
you see that
yeah oh now i gotta win this game
you gotta go you got three seconds oh
but you can
i you got this man just pre-move it out
oh that was also a bad pre-move ah all
right
it was
if you went the other way with your king
here like towards the end when you were
king
on the 63rd movie with king c1
yeah you want king e1 because maurice
had pre-moved
he would put his queen on g2 and that
would have been a stalemate
[Laughter]
wow that was exciting guys great game
just
maurice kung fu sword plays impeccable
that was uh that was remarkable right
there but
just got a chance to revenge here right
you get more shot at it
he does he gets one more chance hey did
you learn anything from that first game
like what are you going to change about
your strategy
what happened
[Laughter]
yeah maurice slashley
[Music]
i hate to give advice in the middle of a
match
given that i you know but since i won
the first game already i'm going to give
you a little bit of advice
you're playing badly on the time you're
not
handling your clock time properly you
got two minutes
and 27 seconds only that you use on the
clock right maybe next time you should
slow it down
and try to you know think about your
moves so you don't make
the same mistakes you played well but
you're playing too fast
although to also give jesus some credit
here you only have 1.6 seconds left the
end of that game yeah
yeah but i was winning like i was still
winning so
so the the point is if he had slowed
down there was a moment in the game we
could talk about it again
afterwards like there are couple of
moments in this game if he had slowed
down he would have found the right moves
yeah i thought about that afterwards it
seemed like i was playing like i only
had 10 seconds left
exactly i want you to do that so
you know be careful because you gotta i
want to show you
not a lot i'm thinking we both had a
minute for some reason i snapped into
that mode
exactly